bienvenidos al nivel 1 de ecuaciones
lineales así que pues vamos a empezar la
primera ecuación que me quiero tomar es
la siguiente 5x y tengo un 5 un poco
gordo pero ahorita a cambio de aprobar
5x igual a 20 y cómo resolvemos esta
ecuación lineal bueno tal vez en un
principio no te parezca tan familiar
esto sin embargo tener esta ecuación es
exactamente lo mismo que pensar en 5 por
álbum 5 por signo de interrogación igual
a 20 siempre que tengamos un número a la
de una variable lo que estamos pensando
es que este número está multiplicando a
mi variable esto es por convención o un
número al lado de una variable se están
multiplicando pero bueno lo que queremos
aquí conocer es a la equis o en su dado
caso a este signo de interrogación es
decir que el número si lo multiplicó por
5 me da 20 y bueno seguramente tú no
puedes decir que esto es muy sencillo 5
por 4 es igual a 20 ahora bien toma en
cuenta que puede ser cualquier número
multiplicando x por lo tanto vamos a
resolverlo de una manera sistemática
aunque en esta ocasión ya sepamos
vamos a ver cómo se refrende si yo tengo
5x igual a 20 y ya tengo una pluma mucho
más delgada 5x igualmente lo que voy a
hacer en el primer procedimiento es
dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre
5 este lado de la ecuación entre 5 y
este lado de la ecuación entre 5 y 5
entre 5 se van me queda 1 por lo tanto
del lado izquierdo me queda x y del otro
lado me queda 20 entre 5 los cuales 4x
es igual a 4 ahora bien también hay otra
forma de resolverlo y déjame copiar aquí
la ecuación original 5x igual a 20 la
otra forma de resolverlo es
multiplicando ambos lados de esta
ecuación por un quinto un quinto por el
lado izquierda de la ecuación y un
quinto por el lado derecho de la
ecuación recuerda que lo que tengo que
hacer donado de la ecuación lo tengo que
hacer del otro lado de la ecuación si tú
estás familiarizado con la
multiplicación de quebrados te vas a dar
cuenta que un quinto por 5 es lo mismo
que uno son recíprocos y por lo tanto me
va a quedar que x es igual a 20 por un
quinto lo cual es 4 al final es lo mismo
lo que estamos haciendo es dividiendo
entre 5 que también es lo mismo que
multiplicar por un quinto pero bueno
vamos a ver un siguiente ejercicio y
déjenme
la pantalla entonces vamos a trabajar
con la siguiente ecuación lineal menos
tres entre cuatro menos tres cuartos que
multiplica x esto lo voy a ser igual a
10 sobre 13 a 10 sobre 13 y bueno como
resuelvo esta ecuación lineal si te das
cuenta es muy parecida a la ecuación
lineal que teníamos hace rato tenemos un
número multiplicando una variable menos
tres cuartos está multiplicando la
variable x por lo tanto para que podamos
resolver esta ecuación lineal lo que
necesitamos hacer es cancelar este menos
tres cuartos para que así me quede la
equis despejada y bueno ya que me estoy
fijando en este - tres cuartos
me pregunto cómo puede pasar del otro
lado de la ecuación o dicho de otra
manera cómo puedo cancelarlo y siguiendo
la misma lógica que vimos ese rato lo
que voy a hacer es multiplicarlo por su
inverso multiplicativo si tú haces un
poco de memoria te vas a dar cuenta que
el recíproco de menos tres cuartos es
cuatro tercios negativo porque date
cuenta si multiplicó a menos cuatro
tercios por menos tres cuartos
esto es lo mismo que uno
fíjate que aquí estoy poniendo un
puntito en medio de estos dos números
este punto significa por 10 que las
convenciones de matemáticas sobre todo
cuando estaban hablando de álgebra se
dieron cuenta que no era nada factible
seguir utilizando la x como x pues no se
confundiría la variable x con la
operación x pero bueno recuerda que lo
que estoy haciendo del lado de la
ecuación lo tengo que hacer del otro
lado de la ecuación y también del lado
derecho voy a multiplicar por menos
cuatro tercios y entonces menos cuatro
tesis por menos tres cuartos esto es lo
mismo que 11 que multiplica x no queda x
mientras que del otro lado de la
ecuación me queda 10 x menos 4 es menos
40 13 por 3 es 39 recuerda cómo se
multiplican las fracciones y ya está
me quedo que x es igual a menos 40 entre
39 esto no se puede simplificar sin
embargo podemos pasar a escribirlo como
una fracción mixta es decir voy a sacar
los enteros que en este caso es un
entero me quedarían menos un entero un
39 menos un entero 1 entre 39 sin
embargo en lo personal yo prefiero verlo
como menos 40 entre 39
sea este tipo de quebrados y bueno ahora
que ya tenemos la respuesta una de las
cosas buenas de tener ecuaciones es que
podemos hacer la comprobación de que
realmente llegamos el resultado correcto
es decir lo que voy a hacer es sustituir
a x por menos 40 entre 39 lo cual yo
digo que es el resultado y voy a ver si
en efecto me da bien sobre 3 y me queda
menos tres cuartos que multiplica a
menos 40 entre 39 esto tiene que ser
igual a 10 sobre 13 es justo lo que yo
quiero ver y bueno de este lado tengo
una multiplicación de fracciones así que
hay que multiplicar el numerador por el
numerador y el denominador por el
denominador y me queda 3 x menos 43 x
menos 40 es lo mismo que menos 120 menos
120 y de hecho mejor déjame ver los de
la siguiente manera porque podemos
empezar a simplificarlo desde acá arriba
si te das cuenta aquí tengo un 4 y quito
un 40 qué pasa si yo saco cuarta tanto
arriba como abajo abajo me queda 1 y
arriba me queda 40 entre 4 de los cuales
10 y está mucho más fácil 3 x menos 10
es lo mismo que menos 30 de hecho menos
x menos me da más 3 por 10 es 30
y después me quedaría 1 por 39 1 por 39
es 39 y a poco 30 entre 39 es lo mismo
que tiene entre 13 pues si si yo saco
tercera arriba y abajo voy a obtener 10
sobre 13 te das cuenta que es justo lo
que yo quería llegar a 10 sobre 13 y ya
con esto ya tengo el resultado acabo de
comprobar que x igual a menos 40 entre
39 es mi respuesta de este segundo
ejercicio así que vamos al último
ejercicio y me queda menos 5 sextos de x
esto quiero que sea igual a menos 7
octavos y si lo quieres intentar por ti
mismo es el momento justo para que
parece el vídeo y no veas la solución
porque justo ahorita voy a empezar con
la solución y bueno la idea es
exactamente la misma que en el ejercicio
pasado voy a multiplicar por el
recíproco de ambos lados de esta
ecuación y luego siempre puede menos 5
sextos es menos 6 quintos entonces voy a
multiplicar menos 6 quintos por esto y
menos 6 quintos por el lado derecho y
menos 6 quintos que multiplica menos 5
sexto se va esto es 1 entonces del lado
izquierdo me queda x mientras que el
lado derecho me queda 7 octavos por
menos 6
aquí puedo simplificar un poco porque -6
tiene mitad que es menos 3 y 8 también
tiene mitad que es 4 por lo tanto puede
significar un poco y me queda 7 x menos
3 lo cual es menos 21 y después 4 por 5
4 por 5 es 20 mi resultado es menos 21
sobre 20 y pues bueno ya está así que
vamos a comprobarlo entonces voy a
sustituir el valor de x y me queda menos
5 sextos por menos 21 sobre 20 esto es
igual a amd y primero voy a sacar aquí
quinta y me quedan 1 arriba y 4 abajo
aquí voy a sacarte el seremi queda 2 y 7
y entonces me va a quedar menos x menos
más 1 por 7 7 y después 2 por 48 que es
justo lo que yo quería era este
resultado de aquí así que ya está ya
tenemos el nivel 1 de ecuaciones
lineales no te pierdas la continuación
en el siguiente vídeo